here is Rachel Levine what is Rachel
Levine's official title she is the
Deputy Health secretary so so he I'm
going to say he because as far as I know
Rachel Levine lived his entire life as a
man was married had kids a couple years
ago decided to become Rachel Levine I
don't know what his genital situation is
I don't really care but what Rachel
Levine has become is one of the key
mouthpieces for not only pushing this
gender stuff into schools and throughout
all of our cultural cultural
institutions but also to ensure that
those of us and I would include myself
in this those of us who speak out
against him and against these really
terrible ideas uh that we will be
silenced by big Tech surprise surprise
technically he is the U.S assistant
secretary for health here's video of
Rachel Levine
so health professionals have a critical
role to play we must continue and to
expand their work to address Health
misinformation directly with their
patients now this includes but it goes
beyond covet 19. so I'd like to just
talk briefly about another area a
substantial misinformation that is
directly impacting Health Equity in our
nation and that is the Health Equity of
sexual and gender minorities
there is substantial misinformation
about gender affirming care for
transgender and gender diverse
individuals we are in this nation facing
an onslaught at the anti-lgbtqi plus
actions at the state levels across the
United States and they are dangerous to
the public health and we need to use our
clinician's voice to collectively
advocate for our tech companies to
create a healthier cleaner information
environment
I think you see what we're doing here
you see why this is all so dangerous so
they confuse you with their language of
gender affirming care while it is
completely unaffirming that's one thing
but then if you talk about it what they
want to make sure just like they did
with covid if you if you have questions
about the vaccine if you don't want
mandates if you just don't feel that the
the machine which has lied about so many
things is is should just be bowed to at
all times they want to make sure that
they can censor you through big Tech or
whatever other means and God only knows
what other means that they have just a
little bit more info on Rachel Levine
Rachel Levine who is 65 year old now 10
years ago divorced his name was Richard
Levine so Rachel Levine used to be
Richard Levine dick Levine so we got
weiner over there and Dick I mean really
this is like the Matrix isn't even
trying anymore it's dropping so many
hints you know so dick Levine uh had two
kids and at 55 years old divorced his
wife Martha that also seems funny to me
only better if it would be Karen so dick
divorces Martha with two kids at 55 and
then puts on a dress and is now the
assistant Health secretary in charge of
making sure that we're going to chop
kids genitals off and silence them
silence the people who oppose it on
Twitter it is just completely ridiculous